now to trending tonight
Hello nice to meet you it's good to see
you I've met you before you'll never
remember it you're kidding would I
that this is great oh God just brace
yourself This is Gonna ruin my day no
it's not
Andy Cohen joins Meghan Markle for her
final episode of archetypes and revealed
Andy kind of turned her down during
suits okay go on season two and we'll
have I was so eager to be on your show
because I was such a Housewives fan at
the time and I just couldn't get booked
Andy that's right Megan admits she was a
huge Housewives fan I guess the million
dollar question is
do you still watch the housewives this
is what we've been dying to know
well I will tell you the truth I stopped
watching the Housewives when my life had
its own level of drama that I stopped
craving
other peoples
I have been waiting decades to do what
I'm getting ready to do now
Hey where's your Snickers Dwayne The
Rock Johnson is writing his wrong with
7-Eleven when I was 14 years old every
day I used to stop here at the 7-Eleven
and steal a king-size Snicker bar
because I couldn't afford to buy one
that was my pre-workout food I did that
for almost a year every day I had to
come back and buy every Snickers bar on
those shows nice to steal the Snickers
every day
[Music]
and he also spreads those Good Vibes to
others
you want anything you got anything
that's just for you thank you so much I
appreciate you I'm gonna leave these
here if somebody looks like they're
stealing Snickers giving me so they
don't steal it thank you and on
newsstands now my name is Billy eilish
Billy eilish Billy eilish Billy eilish
Billy eilish Billy eilish Billy eilish
is back with Vanity Fair for the sixth
year in a row I am feeling
really good it's just so cool to get to
do this every year and this time she's
giving us some tea on her new
relationship I'm really excited and I'm
really happy about it I managed to get
my way to a point in my life my life to
a point where
I Not only was known by a person that I
thought was the hottest alive are you
kidding me
can we just
Round of Applause for me
thank you
Jesse Rutherford everyone and as for why
she does these interviews every year
favorite thing about doing this
interview I don't know I feel really
connected to myself it's really cool to
have these
what five versions of myself
to interact with
[Applause]